this morning we're getting a look at how
one of the nation's biggest retailers
target has been navigating challenges
around the pandemic and economic
uncertainty chairman and CEO Brian
Cornell sat down with Jamie yukas to
talk about company initiatives promoting
equality and diversity that includes a
partnership with one black entrepreneur
Houston White
with Minneapolis Houston White's old
Barbershop has evolved into a place to
grab coffee or buy clothes but at its
core it's a place for the community to
come together black professionals
specifically need a sense of connection
to tribe in place and there's nothing
really in the black community in the
barbershop it's that place that you just
feel like you can breathe and be
yourself so in early 2020 when Brian
Cornell CEO of minneapolis-based Target
heard a group of black employees wanted
him to hear their thoughts I said make
it happen let's pick a spot the spot was
white shop and it was there that the two
men both with a determination to help
other dreamers became friends and he had
this Vision to bring energy and vitality
to this area and it wasn't about him it
was what he could do for Minneapolis and
for other entrepreneurs
three months after white and Cornell met
a Minneapolis Police Officer murdered
George Floyd
I remember Gathering my black officers
right after George Floyd's murder those
team members had tears in their eyes and
they were telling me how it affected
them
their families
since then target has promised to invest
two billion dollars in Black owned
businesses it's preppy and it's cool one
of those businesses you know I'm a
preppy Street kid a new fashion line
designed by a HomeTown Barber with a
passion for clothes I kind of want you
to close your eyes we were there when
Target's Chief merchandising officer
Jill Sandow showed Houston his display
for the first time at a Target that was
rebuilt after being ransacked by looters
in 2020. the city has been through so
much the last couple of years are you
hoping that this somewhat changes the
story of what people think of
Minneapolis
I think it it will we are in the Lake
Street store this is hope this is Joy
this is what's possible and this is how
we're going to bring this community and
Minneapolis forward if this is the
Hustler of the future yes for CBS
mornings Jamie yukas Minneapolis
all right Jamie thank you